So why is what we've covered so
far, important?
Because these are some of the reasons
that the US spends far more per capita.
Typically twice as much on healthcare,
than other advanced
industrialized nations.
That's certainly true if you
again compare the US to France.
Moreover, while increases in US
healthcare spending have slowed in
recent years, for reasons that aren't
yet clear, historically our healthcare
cost have grown much faster than
those in the same group of nations.
The inexorable growth of chronic
disease, is one of the key reasons why.
That spending might be okay if
we were getting a great result.
But again, comparing the US here,
to this group of
industrialized countries and
even some others,
we rank 26th in life
expectancy shown here.
We're also a clear outlier,
spending far more, but
dying younger than the citizens of these
other countries that spend far less.
Clearly a serious problem, but
you may be asking, what does it
have to do with health informatics?
We turn to that now.